[Music]
today in our school matters series we
are answering questions from parents as
kids head back to school we're going to
go over everything from mask wearing to
helping students manage stress
right now covet cases are surging among
children more than 180 thousand new
cases were reported last week alone and
that is a four-fold increase from just a
month ago
our senior medical correspondent dr tara
narula and psychologist and cbs news
contributor lisa demour join us now for
more good morning to both of you tara
good morning table with us so let's
begin with you we've got a viewer
question from rita marie who would like
to know what is the best mask for
children to wear and what is your advice
for choosing a mask in general for
students well let's just start off by
being clear that both the cdc and the
american academy of pediatrics are
recommending universal masking in
schools so yes for many parents on their
shopping list for supplies this year are
masks the best mask most experts will
say is the one that your child will wear
and the one that fits them well so
getting them involved in that choice
picking out the colors and styles they
like or letting them decorate it is
always a good thing when you're picking
out the type you want to pick one that
has multiple layers of material in
particular at least two layers you can
hold it up to the sun and make sure that
you can't see light through it a
surgical mask is a good option and some
parents may feel more comfortable with
those kid-sized kn 95s although for the
child that that may be uncomfortable
it's probably not necessary when you're
looking for what else to choose you want
to choose one that has a nose wire
because that kind of fits nicely around
their face and the ear loops so you can
adjust it so it fits snuggly you want to
make sure you're washing it frequently
if it's not disposable and definitely
pack more than one because my children i
know have lost theirs or they've dropped
on the floor so
no bandanas no i've noticed something
some parents have put it's almost like a
an elastic around the back to keep it on
the ground
like glasses
exactly great idea but kids have been
really great about wearing a mask i
gotta be honest better than many many
adults we're all adjusting to it lisa if
a child is feeling nervous what do you
think parents should do to make them
feel a little better
well always it is the case that kids
take their cues from us about what they
should be nervous about and how nervous
they should be so if they're nervous
about wearing a mask we want to be
really matter of fact about it and just
say you know you're going to wear a mask
so that you feel safe at school and when
you feel safe then you can focus on your
learning and focus on enjoying your
friends
and if they're nervous about going back
to school what we can remember is that
kids are always tense during back to
school time there you know is always a
lot of change change brings about stress
they've got new teachers they've got new
classmates they've got new routines and
so the best thing we can do is to help
them express all of their worries and
then to reassure them to say as soon as
you get into the swing of things this
will all make sense your questions will
be answered and you will feel better hey
lisa i just have one follow-up for you i
mean kids pick up on disagreements among
adults and so they know that there is a
certain percentage of adults who are
saying don't wear a mask and they don't
want their kids to get vaccinated they
don't want their kids to follow the
guidelines what do you say to kids who
are picking up on that and wondering
what's going on here
i think we can say a couple of things
one is that we can say this is what we
are learning from physicians about how
best to keep you safe and we're going to
follow that guidance the other thing i
think we should do is to prepare kids
who go to schools where masks are
optional to prepare them for the
possibility that other kids may ask
questions
and here we can give them a few options
to use depending on the situation they
might say i just feel more comfortable
wearing a mask or we can bear in mind
it's a lot to ask a kid to wear a mask
all day and defend that choice and so we
can tell them just kind of cut them a
break we can say to them feel free to
tell your friends you know yeah it's a
drag it's something my parents are
making me do yeah tara this is this is
not the first year sadly that we've been
sending kids to school in a pandemic
what have doctors learned about keeping
kids safe in the classroom well we've
learned so much since march of 2020 when
all of this started i think one big
thing is that schools are not really the
primary drivers of outbreaks schools are
more of the barometer of what's going on
in the community in terms of
transmission but the second big lesson
is layering layering preventive measures
works it's effective and by that i mean
vaccinating kids who are eligible and
all the adults around the kids teachers
staff parents masking as we've talked
about physical distance so three feet or
more proper ventilation or good
ventilation in schools is key and then
we talked about this last week but rapid
frequent testing both of kids who have
symptoms but also asymptomatic
particularly if there's high levels of
transmission you want to be testing like
once a week in schools we've seen this
work in universities in the past year
and then finally keeping kids home when
they're sick and schools really need to
be flexible with their policies looking
at what's happening in community what
the science says and adapting their
policies accordingly and you know now
the cases with kids are going up you
know when this first started you didn't
have to worry so much about the kids now
you do what concerns you most about that
why is that happening absolutely well
we're at this inflection point where
kids are going back to school we have
delta which is so much more contagious
um and really we have so many kids who
still remain unvaccinated so it's not
surprising that we're going to see this
increase in hospitalizations but what's
concerning is that this rise in
infections means that we have kids who
are now at risk potentially from missed
c kids who may develop long covid we
have that's missing what is that the
multisystem inflammatory condition that
we've seen in over about 4 000 kids in
this country
develop we also have concern for the
fact that more variants can develop as
the virus mutates because it's spreading
kids can transmit to others and then
lastly we are overwhelming or have the
potential to overwhelm our hospital
system there have been so many reports
we've talked about of pediatric icus in
this country being filled up how did we
get to this point there was an article i
read last night by two pediatricians who
said listen our kids have sacrificed so
much for us we need to step up as the
adults and prioritize their health and
do the right thing yeah lisa and tara
you guys are great individually together
this has been terrific i think really
valuable information thank you both very
much